hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with way Jessie and for the
first time a representative of cyndago
on a let's play how cool is that really
I think it's cool how about you mark is
so anyway I played rofl with these guys
they love the game the other two guys
are over there but we only want to keep
it to four players or else it'd be crazy
but we finally decided blitz because
also the game grumps did this on their
livestream and it was a lot of fun so I
am testicle is Jessie is Jessie with
dollar signs and really bad drawing
rhino hazard is ripe o has arrived oh
hey Zuri Wade I'm me okay anyway so
we're gonna play awful if you don't know
what Rafa Lizzie you're about to find
out
they give us things that we draw and
then everyone else has to cast but you
can also try to trick each other very
complicated everyone's going to get to
draw twice which should work perfectly
since there's only four of you playing
let's party there might be a remote
there may be no title to each of your
devices shut up something weird I mean I
can pickpocket or magic smell draw a
picture on your basil so it would have
that title and when you're done hit Send
and you'll get points for each player
that can correctly guess your title so
just try your best
perfect there's no way no one can get
this nobody's going to guess this ever
sits not even real it's real that is not
a real thing don't tell us what it is
okay yeah I'm just kidding I got them
all so now we guess but also we try to
make other that's mine okay that's my
title for this picture could have been
better yeah caution don't say it out
loud what are you doing type in the
singing you big dingus hit the wall
there goes okay but tell me will we okay
pretty sure I have this right hey are
you sure
all right here your choices alien but
son they really inspired this rock I
could be accurate that may be not good
my guess that was very good a lien but
sign really for me well but sex hey
what did everybody pick a little caution
and you get the figure sometimes I like
this piece really caution people
crossing in the ones desire no in
society I ever knew are cautioned people
cross it's just random those freckles
are eyes ah don't uh don't judge me too
harshly here uh oh I didn't know we need
to see by going
let's hope never disappear any of this
is a fear in mark what hey here's
everybody's Pixy doesn't matter what it
really is
see you guys can't laugh me because [ __ ]
you what did you do oh you put fired
what here in the idiot I hate you oh I
love this game am i winning
no okay the guy with zero Wow I know it
which one could it be I wonder
probably acceptable not approval to
actually be acceptable matter boom that
is obviously excessive if anything I
poop a lot what does address yeah I
figure on the same level
we're both taller hey I'm still zero no
penis man yo blurred I'm glad I got this
guy
what wait I'm sorry
this one is good we're gonna be cool
all right who picked what damn it ha ha
ha mini izzle
that's your stupid name yeah you go for
it
score is a genre like ghost Roy that's
stupid
this whole thing's stupid I'm Hamish
routing bye
I did write the exact title uh sucks ass
well you suck how is Jesse winning use
my blade oh no man I can't draw oh my
god that's so horrible oh gee I wonder
I'm supposed to try what are you doing
making fun of me for actually putting
effort into it yeah ok here are your
choices
and here are your picks hahaha bones
obvious now huh Hey oh geez
what oh you all suck Care Bears part of
the in-crowd girl how to get in with
that okay
hey so it's not um I don't know what's
going oh man oh wow here's everybody's
pics
ah I know which one it is yep yeah
that's why we oh yeah yeah I get it now
with the less than now that Axl's does
it apply what's that lime to raise that
in I was trying school Oh how'd you get
2,000 points on that that's a bunch of
bull don't blow Tim what wow oh my god I
may have uh I tried to make it let it
just go baller o'clock at the top just
same amount of cleverness as in the last
what did everybody pick if it's what I
figured
yes we stop giving them points open
anything
[ __ ] funny there's Thomas to be mr.
mimes a Pokeball on top what is [ __ ]
Oh completely go for a Pokemon - mr.
line no actual Mon Oh
draw mine have this like striped
clothing oh yeah this work in a brain
you know half plus time what oh good job
there hey and here are your picks god
damn that broad put ride and lead
cheater with that [ __ ] singing she's
James [ __ ] freakin shoot unless you're
supposed to draw this stage in no no
view alright so thank you everybody so
much for watching drop will hope you
enjoyed that we're gonna play two more
time with the other guys over there
what's his name and what's his face over
there gonna join in the other guys from
cyndago you know before we go do check
out Cindy Gus Channel they have a lot of
cool sketches and music videos over
there they got a lot of fun stuff we've
worked a lot of stuff in the past
wayde's tails in the description
Jessie's Twitter is down there below and
let us know what you thought of this if
you want to see more definitely let us
know and as always we'll see you in the
next video bye
obviously my motivation isn't very like
held on to this something is getting
closer I can feel it I'm sorry I mean
won't happen again that's more like it